an African Army has again struck in
french-speaking Africa it's the 10th
attempted or successful coup on the
continent in three years
the report president of Gabor Ali Bongo
joins the growing list of French allies
sacked by the military in what seems to
be a contagious Trend in West and
central Africa
unlike the coups in Gabon and guinea
growing insecurity is given as the main
cause of the change in governments in
Burkina Faso Mali energy supporters of
the coups in the Sahel Regency France as
propping up leaders who in turn give
unfettered access to their country's
resources
in the last 12 years our Western allies
France especially were more interested
in our resources while we wallow in
poverty and lack of security
for more than half a century been
supplying French nuclear reactors with
uranium fuel but the local population is
particularly unhappy that the former
colonial power has failed to help
improve their lives nor help reigning
attacks by armed groups in Niger and
elsewhere which are some of the reasons
Advanced by leaders of the military coup
last month
of all the countries now under military
rule in the region anti-frank sentiments
are particularly high in Mali and Asia
in Mali the Junta ordered French troops
to leave and that is expected to happen
in Niger
many times what we call diplomacy of
vulnerability the superpowers from
France England everywhere they maintain
Africa in this catastrophic and
vulnerability to to to to to maintain
their diplomacy the population rarely
they want to free themselves
France may be quickly losing its grip
and influence in its former colonies but
analysts say the former colonial power
must change its strategy in relating to
the countries it used to rule if it
wants to remain relevant now
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera nyame
[Applause]
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera